[Musique]
je suis venu chercher de l'or car
tu es né grandi et trouver qu'il y a pas
la famille n'a pas d'argent bon ceux qui
se remet pour toi c'est de combattre
pour chercher de l'argent je suis là
pour chercher de l'or
[Musique]
et ça c'est à vous
qui sort ensemble en même temps et après
vous pouvez prendre une mouchoir enlever
aussi de l'or avec ça le mercredi
leur va rester dans votre main comme ça
[Musique]
maintenant comme il y a l'or qui est
venu donc il y a beaucoup de gens qui
sont venus pour
leur péage donc actuellement
les gens sont venus pour faire leur
péage et il y a beaucoup de drogues qui
est rentré dans dans cette tortillage là
[Musique]